last one mike eardos erdo cerdos hey
guys i'm a big fan of both of yours and
would love to give back for all you do i
am a dentist who practices on the upper
west side and i would be thrilled to
keep your mouth nice and clean at no
charge so that you can keep your jokes
dirty keep your heart up you got
yourself a [ __ ] deal i will be there
you [ __ ] i'm gonna eat a bag of sugar
daddies and a bag of shower patch kids
and tootsie rolls and i'm coming in i'll
be like scraping milk duds yeah
wait wait like get my peter save this
guy's info i'm [ __ ] going in oh yeah
salt water taffy all day i'm gonna suck
a dick drink an eggnog drink two packs
of kool-aid and coming over erdos how do
you feel about fat third wheels
[Laughter]
get some room for salacious in there too
bro oh he's only got four teeth he'll be
fine but i just did a podcast in
portland where the guy gasses you and
does a podcast in the dentist chair he's
a dentist it was a lot of fun
and i got a cleaning but
mark's at the n word so he got cleaning
but he's going to be cancelled
well these teeth they're only whites
but
i haven't gone to the dentist since 88
because you know your parents used to
make you go or mine did and once they
stopped making me as i live in new york
not new orleans i just stopped going i
made an appointment about a year ago and
it was the first time a bit they were
like you haven't seen someone in eight
years and i was just like yeah yeah
they were like that's a really long i
was like i'm doing [ __ ] out here yeah
why don't you get up my [ __ ] back i'm
squeezing [ __ ] titties
oh
that's the last appointment you'll ever
have
and you're not horrible you're not gonna
you don't have bad a dental hygiene no
teeth look great
so maybe these dentists are no offense
they're uh erdos erdos but no let's not
piss them off all right all right
i'm just saying i'm just sitting in the
chair i'm just throwing this tit around
he's like sir please stop playing with
this fake dude
come on
all right erdos well we'll be there get
let's let's look this son of a [ __ ] up
and uh
go in there after a few pops
i'll get a few pops keep sending us
emails we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com we love you we'll sucker your
dickers
and uh we appreciate uh all you guys and
uh
yeah keep keep telling friends about the
patreon we're loving it tell a friend
spread the word peeves drinks wrecks
uh joke ideas uh anything you got movies
whatever we'll take it let's get a quick
plug
let's do it on a regular episode why are
we doing
you might as well sneak it in here too
though all right fine taylor tomlinson
sad in the city new podcast give it a
listen it's i was on episode it's great
it's about taylor being sad in new york
city great presence and uh it makes me
feel great i convinced her to move here
and now their pocket says i'm unhappy
so uh no but it's really great and uh
you should give it a listen and uh
we'll plug in a real episode we should
have plugged in the real one too next
week yeah next week true all right
thanks guys appreciate you comedy